long before President Trump fired FBI
director James Comey he asked him for
his personal loyalty sources close to
CBS News say that the two men had dinner
in January
soon after the inauguration they say
Comey only told the president he would
be honest with him in his first TV
interview since the firing President
Trump called James Comey a showboat
he said the dismissal was his idea he
also said the investigation of Russia
and the election was in his mind when he
let Comey go now that contradicts
statements from others inside the White
House the acting FBI director that's
Andrew McCabe defended Comey yesterday
and said the FBI investigation of
Russian election meddling is quote
highly significant Jeff Pegues is at FBI
headquarters in Washington with details
of commis White House dinner Jeff good
morning good morning that dinner courage
is seven days into the Trump
administration and by that time the FBI
was already investigating whether Trump
campaign associates were coordinating
with the Russians during the 2016
campaign I had a dinner with him he
wanted to have dinner because he wanted
to stay on with in an interview with NBC
News President Trump detailed his
private January conversation with then
FBI director James Comey a dinner was
arranged I think he has for the dinner
and he wanted to stay on as the FBI head
and I said you know consider we'll see
what happens but we had a very nice
dinner and at that time he told me you
are not under investigation but law
enforcement sources who spoke to Comey
tell a different story
they say Comey was invited to the White
House where the president asked the FBI
director if he would pledge his loyalty
to the president Comey declined instead
telling Trump he would always be honest
the president twice more pressed Comey
for loyalty the third time asking for
honest loyalty to that Comey responded
yes you will have that there is no
collusion between me and my campaign and
the Russians inside FBI headquarters
there are growing concerns the White
House is trying to get in the way of the
bureau's Russia investigation calling
crisis one federal law enforcement
official tells CBS News there is a whole
lot of interfering happening but sources
are telling us
agents are pushing ahead with the Russia
investigation despite the turmoil
swirling around them the White House was
floating the idea of President Trump
coming down here to FBI headquarters
today but that idea has been scrapped we
did reach out to the White House for
comment on the president's dinner with
Comey but so far we have not heard back
all right
Jeff thank you so much